beim kampf gegen das virus abwarten oder
lockern streit und corona maßnahmen
unser thema in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
schon guten abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus berlin ich darf meine
gäste vorstellen bei uns ist kirsten
kaputt konter von bündnis 90 die grünen
sie ist stellvertretende vorsitzende des
gesundheitsausschusses im bundestag
schönen guten abend und
herz hallo frau prettner hanna die runde
herzlich willkommen gitta connemann von
der cdu stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende und vorsitzende der
mittelstands- und wirtschaftsunternehmen
guten haben und hier im studio begrüße
ich christina satori diplom biologin und
freie wissenschaftsjournalistin
und ralf schuler leiter der
parlamentsredaktion der bild zeitung
frau connemann mit ihnen würde ich gerne
beginnen wir haben jetzt eine
ankündigung dass bayerns
ministerpräsident müller gesagt hat die
impfpflicht für menschen im
gesundheitswesen sie zum 15 märz der in
kraft treten soll der sie zugestimmt
haben der auch bayern zugestimmt hat im
bundesrat da hat er gesagt wie will er
so nicht umsetzen wie finden sie das
ministerpräsident müller hat nicht
gesagt rwe so nicht umsetzen sondern er
will sie aussetzen und damit reagiert er
auf einen hilferuf sowohl der kommunen
als auch zum beispiel von verbänden von
pflegediensten und so weiter ich habe
selbst für die einrichtungs bezogen der
impfpflicht gestimmt und zwar voller
überzeugung denn es geht um mitarbeiter
die mit besonders gefährdeten menschen
zu tun haben in bern nahmen kontakt
stehen und da geht es um das thema
schutz
inzwischen und viele kommunen viele auch
pflegeverbände standen hinter diesem
gesetz berufen aber inzwischen halt und
stopp weil sie sagen die umsetzung des
gesetzes kann nicht gelingen es wird ein
problem geben und dies wird zu einem
kollaps führen und politik muss sich
immer wieder auch beraten lassen
insbesondere wenn hilferufe aus der
praxis kommen und ich erwähne insoweit
nur beispielsweise die
gesundheitsminister der länder die am 22
januar gefordert hatten dass man zu
abgestimmten bund länder
ausführungsbestimmungen kommen der
gesundheitsminister herr lauterbach
hatte sato allerdings nichts vorgelegt
das heißt das gesetz wurde geschlossen
und noch einmal hier stehen unter dieser
einrichtung bezogenen impfpflicht aber
sind zwei monate ins land gegangen in
den viele fragen nicht geklärt werden
konnten so sagen die kommunen unsere
gesundheitsämter werden ist nicht
umsetzen können was ist auf jeden
verkauften leitplanken lästige geld des
bundes und darauf warten genau diese und
fordern deshalb eine verlängerung der
frist und eine aussetzung nun hätte man
das ja auch vorher bedenken können bevor
man zustimmt und was noch mal was ist
das für ein signal wenn ein
ministerpräsident sagt ich setze das
nicht um weil das auch wenn man sagt er
und setzt es aus dann heißt es ja
trotzdem setzt es nicht um der
bundeskanzler sagt er erwartet von den
ländern gesetzestreue das erwartet man
von den bürgern ja auch dass sie sich an
die maßnahmen halten
absolut aber ein gesetz muss umgesetzt
werden können und verzeiht lagen uns die
kommunen die es umsetzen müssen mit
ihrem gesundheitsämtern dass sie es
nicht können das heißt diejenigen die
vollziehen sollen sind sie dazu nicht in
der lage weil ihnen die
ausführungsbestimmungen und die
leitplanken des bundes fehlen und es ist
nicht aufgabe des gesetzgebers solche
bestimmungen zu erarbeiten wie mache ich
zb ein betretungsverbot wie kläre ich
auch rechtsfragen das ist aufgabe der
bundesregierung die bundesregierung hat
inzwischen diese fragen nicht geklärt
und vor diesem hintergrund ist es nur
eine fürsorgepflicht der auch minister
söder nach ministerpräsident soll danach
kommt wenn er darauf hört das caritas
wie städtetag und landkreistag sagen es
wird zu einem chaos kommen wenn er
darauf hört und sagt wir wollen umsetzen
aber wir brauchen mehr zeit und die
bundesregierung muss jetzt endlich die
offenen fragen klären und die
leitplanken vorbei frau k but what was
sagen sie dazu wenn
ministerpräsident oder sagt er will das
so oder er kann es nicht umsetzen
verstehen sie die bedenken die es gibt
von kommunen die sagen eigentlich
funktioniert das so nicht
ich halte das inhaltlich für völlig
falsch dieses gesetz jetzt noch weiter
verzögern zu wollen
und ich halte es auch für das völlig
falsche signal
weil wir haben ja diese einrichtungs
bezogene endlich genau deshalb im
gesetzestext gegossen damit die uns in
den pflegeheim in den krankenhäusern in
den einrichtungen anvertrauten menschen
die möglichst die bestmögliche
sicherheit haben und das heißt eben auch
dass wir von staatswegen dafür sorge
tragen müssen dass menschen die eben in
einem krankenhaus kommen nicht noch ein
zusätzliches risiko haben sich
anzustecken über ungeimpfte
pflegepersonal von daher finde ich es
inhaltlich absolut notwendig dass wir
sagen wir setzen alles daran damit diese
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
funktionieren kann und ich halte es eben
auch als signal für völlig falsch zu
sagen da gibt es ein bundesgesetz das
ist mit breiter mehrheit in diesem
deutschen bundestag beschlossen worden
und einstimmig vom bundesrat das heißt
unter zustimmung aller
landeschefs besprochen vereinbart worden
dass dieses gesetz jetzt von bayern
nicht vollzogen werden soll wir erwarten
dass sich alle an die geltenden regeln
halten wir können ja auch nicht uns
vorstellen dass ministerpräsident söder
jetzt auf einmal sagt bei uns gilt aber
nicht mehr wer bei rot über die ampel
geht dass das gilt einfach nicht
bundesgesetze gelten für uns nicht
sondern bundesgesetze gelten und dieses
ist aus gutem grund beschlossen worden
von daher halte ich es für völlig falsch
was da jetzt in aussicht gestellt wird
der browser thorium was würden sie sagen
was ist das für ein signal wenn jetzt
aber auf der anderen seite heißt viele
können es gar nicht umsetzen sagen das
funktioniert so nicht ist es zwar ist zu
kurz gesprungen
mich wundert ein bisschen dass das jetzt
ein paar tage bevor es losgehen soll
passiert also erst am 15
also kurz vorher das hätte auch sehr
kurzfristig dieses gesetzes schon vor
einiger zeit geschlossen worden und
jetzt
lange davor darüber diskutiert worden
also ich denke es ist kein gutes signal
da jetzt einen rückzieher zu machen
sondern man sollte sich eher überlegen
wie können wir denn die kommunen
unterstützen was ist denn da das problem
also gibt es nicht genug kontrollen
müssen die am anfang denn so eng sein
wie können wir denn da und wir helfen
und ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen
dass das wirklich so viele pflegekräfte
dadurch dann ausfallen würden also
vielleicht lässt sich ja der eine oder
andere noch impfen und ich find's auch
ein ganz fatales signal für die
allgemeine impfpflicht weil ich sehe
dass nur als ersten schritt es reicht
nicht wenn es nur eine impfpflicht gibt
für die pflegekräfte das reicht nicht um
dieses virus einzudämmen es muss auch
eine allgemeine impfpflicht geben und
wenn es jetzt bei diesem schon
verabschiedeten gesetz plötzlich solche
probleme gibt wie soll das denn
weitergehen aber wenn jene machen sie
dafür jetzt verantwortlich das ist so
nicht dass das nicht gut funktioniert
also in diesem falle würde ich sagen
herr söder das kann nicht sein dass ihr
jetzt gesagt wird jetzt plötzlich hören
wir dass es nicht immer umsetzbar ist
da muss ein politiker am ein
landespolitiker auch dann für für seinen
für sein bundesland irgendwie eine
lösung finden es liegt ja es ist ja wohl
auch so dass ein höherer prozentsatz an
pflegekräften in bayern noch nicht
geimpft ist als zum beispiel in anderen
bundesländern also nrw denke ich mal hat
zum beispiel dieses problem nicht weiter
der allergrößte teil der pflegekräfte
geimpft ist da ist die angst nicht so
groß dass wichtige das ist eine große
menge von pflegekräften abspringt dann
muss einfach noch mehr denn da muss man
in die krankenhäuser gehen die einnahmen
noch mehr aufklären und noch mehr
irgendwie an die leute ran gehen und
sagen es ist aber wichtig der schule
moment nicht merkt oberschule mit den
diskussionen der shooter ist das ja ein
kräftemessen jetzt wo das
ministerpräsident so dass zeigen will
hier und märz hat ihm ja auch
beigepflichtet das sozusagen die cdu/csu
ihre oppositionsrolle da wahrnehmen will
oder geht es wirklich darum das ist
ebenso nicht es ist zum teil ein
puzzlestück aus dem allgemeinen chaos
bild corona politik söhne hat einfach
nur die notbremse gezogen die er
eigentlich schon bei der abstimmung im
bundesrat hätte ziehen müssen aber es
gibt natürlich eine ganze menge von
normal haltungsnoten die man in dieser
ganzen frage vergeben hat und wo man
sich nicht erwischen lassen will man
muss einfach wissen es gibt eine
fachkraftquote in pflege das bedeutet
man kann die gesamte einrichtung nur am
leben halten wenn eine bestimmte quote
von pflegern dort ist dann kann man die
anderen pfleger mit dazu holen und das
funktioniert wenn die quote
unterschritten wird muss man die gesamte
einrichtung schließen das ist einfach
ein riesen problem hätte man vorher
wissen können aber ich finde es ein
bisschen kurz gesprungen wenn man sagt
wir haben mox beschlossen jetzt ziehen
wir den mops einfach durch weiß das
falsche signal ist es ist problematisch
den leuten zu erklären die hoch
dringliche quote in pflegeheimen die wir
als erstes durchgepeitscht haben die
setzen wir jetzt aus aber wir machen
schon mal die allgemeine also die
allgemein aber wir weitermachen also
wenn das jetzt hier nicht funktioniert
finde ich ist es in der tat schwierig
den leuten zu erklären warum sie jetzt
alle sich impfen lassen müssen wenn es
die pfleger schon einig sind und ich
finde aber hätten die allgemeine nämlich
vielleicht früher machen sollen weil
viele pfleger haben ja auch gesagt warum
sollen wir uns denn jetzt eigentlich
also warum warum müssen wir das jetzt
die sowieso schon schwere lasten tragen
das wäre dann das wäre die konsequenz
gewesen ich halte auch die allgemeine
impfpflicht nicht für plausibel aber das
ist eine andere frage man muss sich auch
angucken wie der
bundesgesundheitsminister agiert in dem
jüngsten interview gestern im zdf da hat
er gesagt ja es gehe auch darum dass die
pfleger eine geringere virus last tragen
und weniger infektiös sind durch die
impfung das stimmt im gleichen atemzug
erklärt er hinterher dass die jungen
menschen die in discos gehen
hinterher infektiöser sind und die alten
menschen anstecken also was ist jetzt
die
jungen menschen die in die disco gehen
die sind auch geimpft zu hohem maße
beispiel war israel und die sind dann
plötzlich infektiöser bei der
argumentation mit den altenheimen sagt
er nein die sind nicht so infektiös das
ist einfach nicht konzise und die
tucholsky hat mal gesagt die menschen
wissen nicht alles aber sie ahnen häufig
richtig und in dem fall finden sie es
nicht prosieben hat der
bundesgesundheitsminister vorlaut aber
hat auch gesagt es entsteht der eindruck
dass politik erpressbar sei also ist
dieser protest dass man dieser protest
jetzt auf einmal wichtiger ist als der
schutz der menschen in
pflegeeinrichtungen was sagen sie denn
dazu
also entschuldigung ich habe den
eindruck dass weder der
gesundheitsminister macht teile in
dieser runde in der letzten zeit mal mit
betroffenen gesprochen haben wenn frau
satori gerade sagt ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass es so ist dann würde ich
empfehlen sich mal zum beispiel mit dem
städtetag landkreistag und städte- und
gemeindebund zusammenzusetzen umfragen
gemacht haben bei ihren kommunen die
kommunen zurück spiegeln wir werden es
nicht umsetzen können weil zum beispiel
rechtsfragen geklärt sind gibt es ein
betretungsverbot gibt es ein
tätigkeitsverbot wie sollen wir damit
umgehen und das über ich habe heute aber
sie haben mit unterschiedlichen aber sie
haben dem gesehen aber sie haben mit dem
gesetz zu schreiben ich habe dem gesetz
zugestimmt und steht zu dieser
zustimmung es geht darum dass sich jetzt
zeigt dass das was wir beschlossen haben
nicht in der zeit bis zum 16 märz
umgesetzt werden kann und dann ist
politik doch tatsächlich gut beraten
darauf zu reagieren oder wollen wir
gegen eine wand fahren nur weil die
recht behalten wollen das hört sich so
an die diskussionen
weil sie gesagt dann sie können es sich
nicht vorstellen frau sator ich habe
heute nachmittag noch mit dem leiter
einer behinderteneinrichtung gesprochen
aus niedersachsen hat also gar nichts
mit bayern zu tun in niedersachsen ist
die situation noch relativ gut 90
prozent der pflegekräfte sind in diesem
frei sind in seiner einrichtung nur in
anführungsstrichen
65 mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
betroffen 65 mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter in einer zeit in der sein
fachkräfte mal in der eigentlich ohnehin
offene stellen hat diese 65
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter werden
ab dem 16 märz nicht mehr zur verfügung
steht wie stellen sie sich jetzt zum
teil schon arbeitslos gehen in anderen
branchen sie können oder eben viele
ratschläge wo sie können sich impfen
lassen kann man sich aber sie können es
nicht erzwingen und wenn diese
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern und
sagt ich lasse dich zwingen und ich
glaube einen impfzwang jetzt ja noch
nicht angedacht von der ampel dann ist
das problem dass ab dem 16 märz 65
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter allein
in dieser einrichtung
ignorieren zu lassen aber mit denen
argument hätte man gar nicht mehr im weg
das wäre ein versäumnis von politik und
ich möchte dann sehen dass frau kaputt
runter oder anderen mitglieder auch der
ampeln dann in diesem heim
beispielsweise sind und aus helfen das
kann kein mensch vorstellen
die menschen
die betroffen das gros seiner frau
satori frau kate konnte herrscht erstmal
ist ja noch nicht klar dass diese 65
mitarbeiter alle kündigen werden das
sagen sie vielleicht jetzt aber das
wissen sie ja noch gar nicht dann kann
es ja gut sein es wird für viele
menschen die sagen die sich nicht impfen
haben impfen lassen bis sie haben gesagt
ich habe angst vor diesem rna impfstoff
kann man halten was man will
wissenschaftlich gesehen macht das nicht
wie sind aber es gibt ja jetzt diesen
tod im stoff nowak das kann gut sein
dass die eine oder andere sich dadurch
doch noch zum impfen überreden lässt ich
könnte mir auch vorstellen dass der ein
oder andere sich lieber impfen lässt als
dass er arbeitslos wird also von daher
glaube ich lasse mich ja auch nur
prognosen die sie da kennen so ich weiß
nicht ob sie da so viel mehr wissen als
ich und noch was als sie das gesetz mit
verabschiedet haben da wussten sie doch
wie hoch die quote ist von menschen die
sich nicht impfen lassen wollen in
solchen pflegeeinrichtungen da verstehe
ich nicht wieso sie jetzt erst sagen das
ist ein problem das wusste man schon
damals dass er von anfang an ein
argument in der diskussion
und wenn sie damals mit bestimmter
werden entschuldigung jetzt bin ich dran
ja jetzt hab ich jetzt lassen sie mich
bitte ausreden danke und wenn sie damals
dafür gestimmt haben dann haben sie doch
damals auch gedacht irgendwie lösen wir
das problem da muss es doch eine lösung
für geben das kann doch nicht sein
der bundestag beschließt den politischen
willen zu diesem gesetz danach werden
die ausführungsbestimmungen von der
legislative von der exekutive gemacht
und die müsst dann einfach entweder das
land oder aber in diesem container
bundesgesundheitsminister liefern wenn
das nachfolgende hätte das land ja auch
zb in bayern vielleicht versuchen müssen
dass mehr leute sich impfen lassen ja
das ist das aber eine andere baustelle
also wenn man wenn ich die impfpflicht
beschließen muss man der
bundesgesundheitsminister
sagen die die die vorlage liefern für
die ausführungsbestimmungen und dann
kann das umgesetzt werden das ist
eigentlich ein eher einen technischer
prozess dass das manchmal zeitlich in
verzug gerät ist eine andere frage ob
das politische implikationen hat kann
ich jetzt noch nicht sagen magath konnte
also man muss doch gucken möchte man
etwas ermöglichen oder möchte man etwas
verhindern
und wir befinden uns alle in dieser
pandemie und wir sind uns ja
wahrscheinlich in die der runde einig
dass impfen ein wesentlicher schlüssel
raus aus der pandemie ist und dass wir
mit menschen die besonders wohl habe
sind dass wir für die auch eine
bestimmte schutzpflicht von staatswegen
haben und das ist ja der grund warum wir
diese alge die
einrichtungs bezogen der impfpflicht
beschlossen haben und jetzt halte ich
mich gerade versprochen und habe von der
allgemeinen impfpflicht gesprochen ich
bin auch der auffassung dass wir die
allgemeine impfpflicht ab 18 jetzt auch
zügig auf den weg bringen sollten jetzt
kann man sich angucken wer ist quasi das
team ermöglichung und wir haben bisher
ein einziges bundesland und dass es
bayern repräsentiert jetzt von
ministerpräsidenten söder der sagt er
wird dieses gesetz erst mal nicht in die
umsetzung bringt alle anderen
bundesländer und kommunen sind jetzt
gerade dabei zu versuchen und alles was
in ihrer möglichkeit steht dafür zu tun
dass sie diese im pflicht in den
entsprechenden einrichtungen auch
umsetzen und wir wissen eben dass es
große unterschiede gibt auch sozusagen
in den landstrichen aber eben auch in
den bundesländern wie hoch die
impfquoten sind und das hat natürlich
auch was mit dem engagement zu tun der
länder um für eine hohe impfrate zu
sorgen und wenn wir jetzt unseren
ehrgeiz und unser engagement darauf
richten menschen die bisher nicht
geimpft ist sind dafür zu gewinnen sich
noch impfen zu lassen dann halte ich das
für wesentlich zielführender als sich
quasi in eine trotz ecke zu stellen und
zu sagen das machen wir nicht und den
allgemeinen fachkräftemangel der ja im
übrigen noch zunehmen wird in zukunft
und zwar nicht wegen der allgemein wegen
der einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht
sondern weil da eben aufweichen bisher
nicht gut gestellt wurden den jetzt
gegen die frage auszuspielen
riskieren wir es dass menschen in
einrichtungen
durch personal infiziert war das halte
ich für wirklich falsch also unser
engagement muss sein jetzt die menschen
dafür zu gewinnen und wir haben ja ein
gutes argument gehört nowaks ist jetzt
in der zulassung ist es auch nochmal
eine möglichkeit und wir können auch
lernen von den einrichtungen die eine
sehr hohe importe haben wie machen die
das da das gespräch zu suchen
beispielsweise ich vertrete das
bundesland bremen hier ist es eine
rarität wenn eine person in einer
einrichtung noch nicht geimpft ist und
da miteinander in kontakt zu gehen und
zu fragen wie gewinnt man leute dafür
und nicht zu sagen wir setzen das nicht
um und damit auch so was wie einen
freibrief zu erteilen das wäre der
wesentlich sinnvoller was heißt das nun
aber wenn man die heimat wird der
fairness halber nur noch einmal um
klarstellung
ministerpräsident sagt nicht er setzt
sich nicht oben es geht um eine
aussetzung um zeit zu gewinnen damit
unter anderen die kommunen sich auch
einstellen können sich bitte an dieser
stelle sehr
relevant ansehen dann würde ich doch
darum bitten dass die wenig mit zum
beispiel den caritasverband passau
sprechen ja das ist ok weil ich gleich
kunden ich glaube die botschaft ist
angekommen was heisst das aber jetzt für
die allgemeine impfpflicht und für die
überhaupt die kurs ende der der kurs in
der pandemie frau satori wenn man ja
zieht da ist halt eben die breite
mehrheit die eigentlich dieses die rein
rechts produktbezogene impfpflicht ja
gemeinsam entschieden hat im bundestag
und bundesrat jetzt bericht dass er
darum was auseinander was heißt das denn
zum beispiel für die allgemeine
vielleicht ja ich hoffe dass das nicht
noch noch noch mehr dazu führt dass sie
die allgemeine impfpflicht noch weiter
heraus gezögert wird weil jetzt langsam
läuft und auch die zeit davon wir sind
jetzt zwar noch im frühjahr aber es will
ja keiner noch mal so einen herbst
erleben also ich glaube die leute machen
das auch nicht mehr mit ich glaube wenn
jetzt ein guter sommer kommt und er wird
kommen allein schon durch die
temperaturen und sowas und die leute
dann einmal wieder gewöhnt sind ohne
massnahmen zu leben wenn dann noch ein
herbst kommt und wir immer noch diese im
pflücke haben und es dann wieder heißt
um das gesundheitssystem nicht zu
überlasten weil wir zu viele ungeimpfte
haben müssen wir wieder diese und jene
maßnahmen machen ich glaube die leute
machen dann nicht mehr mit und dann
wird's echt blöd und deswegen ist es so
wichtig dass wir jetzt allgemeine
impfpflicht bald durch kriege und ich
wundere mich sowieso warum da so lange
jetzt rum diskutiert wird und rum
geschachert wird und jetzt auch noch so
was bei einem gesetz war schon
verabschiedet ist ich hoffe wirklich
dass das nicht dazu beiträgt dass die
allgemeine impfpflicht so verzögert weil
das können wir uns nicht leisten erst
schule haben sie den eindruck dass es
jetzt dass der gemeinsame politische
wille den dingen die pandemie zu
bekämpfen dass das jetzt auseinander
bricht also ich nehme schon zur kenntnis
und daher stimmig frau satorius direkt
zu dass die leute das nicht mehr
mitmachen ich fürchte nur dass die
allgemeine impfpflicht ein weiterer
stein da zu sein wird dass sie nicht
mehr mitmachen wir haben doch in der
pandemie gelernt dass wir eigentlich
immer erst hinterher wissen wie das
virus funktioniert und wir haben auch
gelernt dass wir erst sehr spät
mitbekommen haben wie der impfstoff
funktioniert mit blick auf bestimmte
varianten also zu glauben dass wenn wir
jetzt aus der kenntnis des letzten
herbst ist eine impfpflicht eine
allgemeine beschließen die dann in der
lage sein wird die dann aktuelle virus
variante zu bekämpfen dass das ist
irrsinn also die
bafin das virus status wäre schon bei
der grippeschutzimpfung haben sie jedes
jahr varianten die sie mit dem neuen
impfstoff nicht mehr erreichen und immer
nur eine gewisse prophylaxe dahin
kriegen das ist bei der grippe okay wer
aber wir haben wir uns doch nichts das
beispiel bremen ist ja schon gefallen
bremen hatte die höchsten impfquote
hatte eine der bundesweit höchsten
instanzen und die und das krankenhaus
krankenhäuser waren nicht überlastet vor
diesem hintergrund jetzt irgendwelche
die hohe quote wurde das weil wir wissen
auch dass die inzidenz eigentlich nicht
mehr der messwert ist wenn wir jetzt die
der bundesgesundheitsminister hat gerade
einen fulminanten begründung wechsel
hingelegt und hat ist umgeschwenkt von
der überlastung des gesundheitswesens
zur zahl der toten das kann man ja
machen nur je öfter man die begründung
für etwas wechselt desto weniger
glaubwürdig ist das draußen und ich sehe
einfach nicht dass wir jetzt wissen
welche form die pandemie im herbst
annimmt es gibt auch die theorie unter
virologen dass ein virus je öfter ist
mutiert desto harmloser wird ist ob die
stimmt weiß ich nicht ich stimmt nicht
gut sagen die meisten biologen sagen
nein das stimmt nicht da diese
sicherheit haben sie nicht sie wissen
nicht was sie für mutation
ist jetzt etwas nur ich sehe einfach
nicht dass wir beschlüsse fassen können
die im herbst wirksam sind die
unionsfraktion will am freitag sich
erstmals beraten über eine vorsorge
gesetz für eine allgemeine impfpflicht
das dann scharf gestellt werden soll
wenn es wirklich nötig ist das sind aber
meistens administrative regeln die das
gebäude
nach oben bringen volker barth konnte
sie wollten dazu was sagen
ja also genau das ja wir haben im
europäischen vergleich nur eine mittlere
impfquote weiß wir haben eine enorme
lücke und die müssen wir schließen damit
wir eben genau das was eben schon
angesprochen wird auch erreichen können
nämlich die entkopplung der inzidenz von
krankenhausaufenthalten und todesfällen
und wir dürfen nicht davon ausgehen dass
eine weitere mutation harmloser wäre
oder
sich auch so verhält wie omikron weil es
ist nicht richtig
medizinisch und ich bin ja ärztin und
425 jahre auch ärztlich gearbeitet dass
dieses virus quasi in reihe mutiert ja
sondern die ich die mutationen gehen
quasi alle nebeneinander her und
parallel von dem ursprung stamm
ausgehend und es ist nicht sehr
wahrscheinlich dass eine mutation die
uns im herbst erreichen wird besonders
harmlos sein wird sondern das gegenteil
ist der fall das heißt wir müssen jetzt
dafür sorge tragen dass wenn eine neue
virus mutation und ziele erreichen wird
dass das möglichst auf eine bevölkerung
trifft die sehr flächendeckend geimpft
und zwar mehrfach geimpft und dann auch
gewusst hat ist
nicht auf den weg bringen
habe ich noch die
impfstoffe funktionieren
ja dass die mma impfstoffe die
erreichen ja sozusagen das
das entscheidende des virus und die die
kleinen zusatz bikes die die
unterschiedlichen varianten ausmachen
die werden dann quasi durch eine
adaptation des impfstoffes noch mal
zusätzlich abgedeckt aber die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass der impfstoff
den die meisten von uns ja jetzt auch
schon bekommen haben wahrscheinlich hier
in der runde nämlich die mma impfstoffe
auch durchaus einen guten schutz bieten
gegenüber nächsten mutationen dass es
eben sehr hoch und zusätzlich kommt es
fakt der faktor dass hier die firmen zum
beispiel bei antec schon angekündigt
haben dass sie eine mr in einem stoff
auch sehr schnell auf eine neue mutation
daneben anpassen
auch mit den klassischen impfstoff und
impfung haben wir eine hohe
wahrscheinlichkeit dass die tatsächlich
auch für eine eventuelle mutationen die
uns im herbst erreichen wird frau aus
wirksam sind okay frau konnte man was
bedeutet das so wie es jetzt mit dir mit
der einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht
ist wo sie da ihre kritik daran haben
und sagen das müssen wir ausnutzen von
nachbessern was bedeutet das denn jetzt
von seiten der cdu csu rufe die
allgemeine impfpflicht wie werden sie
sich denn da verhalten wurden
wir werden am freitag
in unserer fraktion über einen antrag
entsprechen wir mir als antrag in die
innstädter einbringen werden zur
wahrheit gehört ja dass zwar viel über
allgemeine nicht gesprochen wird dass
sich die gruppen anträge angekündigt
sind aber bislang nur ein einziger
antrag auf dem tisch dann nämlich einen
antrag ein der aus der fdp heraus die im
schlicht abnehmen etwas anderes gibt es
zurzeit nicht
übrigens steht debatte auch noch nicht
auf der tagesordnung des deutschen
bundestages
das heißt wir sind absolut auch im 22
wir ziehen uns nicht darauf zurück zu
sagen dass die abend nicht einig ist an
dieser stelle denn es ist ja deutlich
der eine bilden schlecht auf 18 der
nächsten 50 jahre gar keine nicht dass
die ampel ist gar nicht in der lage
dieses thema allein zu schultern
darauf werden wir uns aber nichts
produzieren sondern wir planen in diesem
kontext eine in vorsorge gesetz wenn wir
erkennen dass derzeit kein gesetz in der
lage übrigens wäre omikron zu begegnen
jedes gesetz aktuell pläne zu spät und
es wäre auch die frage ob ein schwerer
grundrechtseingriff und das ersten in
chrom nicht missverstehen ich bin
geimpft ich bin bewusst ich werbe für
impfung denn ich weiß dass man sich
damit schützt und damit auch der letzte
gesundheitssystem schützt aber dennoch
bleibt es ein schwerer
grundrechtseingriff und für diesen
schweren grundrechtseingriff hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht im letzten jahr
bestimmte kriterien formuliert
abgesprochen das ist ein ziel geben muss
sein zweck einen hintergrund und es ist
ziel kann nur ist es nur legitim einen
solchen ein wirt zu vollziehen wenn es
sich um den schutz von kritischer
infrastruktur handelt oder aber eben um
die sicherstellung der
gesundheitsversorgung alle diese
kriterien werden werth hat beim micro ma
nicht gegeben wir dürfen aber und da
sind wir uns einig dass wänden eine
schwerere mutante wieder kommen sollte
wenn wir in den herbst in den winter
geben wenn wir keine lockdown wollen
müssen wir uns vorbereiten und in diesem
fall einen vorsorge gesetzt indem wir
heute definieren über welchen kriterien
am ende eine impfpflicht dann auch
scharf gestellt werden könnte aber es
wird immer eine einzelfallbezogene
prüfung erforderlich sein dann wäre das
nicht so wie frau satori sagt das kann
doch nicht sein doch es natürlich
bestimmte rechts kämpfen das sind am
ende grundrechte die nur bestimmten
schranken unternehmer das heißt die
verfassungsjuristen
sagen uns an dieser stelle zurzeit wäre
eine impfpflicht gar nicht gar nicht
verhältnismäßig wir gar nicht kino i
also nur sollen weil jeder gelegenheit
haben ja das darf nicht passieren
momentan will ich würde gern auch dass
wenn ich bin ich nur über die endlich
drehen weil ich würde gern noch ein
bisschen darüber auch reden über die
frage der lockerungen wie viele
maßnahmen wir eigentlich noch brauchen
und wie viel eigenverantwortung auch der
bürger sie haben sie eben dieser browser
tore die bürger machen das irgendwann
nicht mehr mit jetzt schauen viele
bürger nach dänemarks da werden die
maßnahmen gelockert und sagen jetzt bei
omikron wir kriegen das langsam alle wir
werden nicht schwer krank es wird jetzt
zeit dass wir hier auch lockern was
sagen sie denen ja wird zeit dass wir
auch lockern wenn wir den höhepunkt der
welle hinter uns haben also im moment
ist der trend ansteigend die infektionen
nehmen noch zu und wir wissen dass das
ist das schöne omikron führt sehr viel
seltener zu einem schweren verlauf aber
bitte omikron ist keine kleinigkeit also
es gibt leute die liegen schwer krank
beatmet im krankenhaus mit omikron und
das sind vor allen dingen die
ungeimpften und das hat und noch ist
dieses virus auch vor allen dingen in
der jüngeren generation verbreitet die
er sowieso besser geschützt ist also
nicht ganz so anfällig ist für einen
schweren verlauf keiner weiß ob dieses
virus sich noch in deutschland in der
älteren generation verbreiten wird dann
können sich die hospitalisierung zahlen
die immer auch nocht nicht runtergehen
der trend ist gerade so naja muss man
mal abwarten könnte auch noch nach oben
gehen das muss man auch abwarten er sich
es mag ja sein dass es sind dass es klug
ist sich jetzt über schon mal zu
überlegen wie gehen wir dann
schrittweise vor aber irgendwie
anzufangen mit lockerungen bevor
überhaupt diese dieser höhepunkt
erreicht ist das macht doch kein mensch
während r ga warum brauchen menschen
eine perspektive dass man sagt dann also
der gesundheitsminister hat jetzt gesagt
los dann könnte er sich vorstellen noch
vor ostern lockt genau es heißt ja auch
immer und das sagt ja auch zum beispiel
das robert-koch-institut wenn der
höhepunkt erreicht ist dann können wir
darüber reden dann kann man darüber
nachdenken
und wenn man ins ausland guckt dann
sollte man noch mal genauer hingucken
weil dänemark hat eine ganz andere
impfquote als wir vor allem bei den
älteren da sind wir noch hatten
und die haben übrigens auch probleme mit
der infrastruktur weil sie so viele
unfälle haben aber das wird dann so
hingenommen in großbritannien hat eine
andere impfquote und die haben immer
noch seit wochen seit monaten 200 tote
am tag auch das muss man hinnehmen muss
man akzeptieren das kostet auch so eine
freiheit und in frankreich gelten
strengere regeln als bei uns zum
beispiel da können sie nicht ece fahren
wenn sie um geimpft sind die an die
debatte muss ich so denken wie es jetzt
um die endlich geht weil was hieß ist
hier in deutschland oder das geht nicht
3g in den zügen das geht nicht da und
die franzosen das schon lange gemacht
und jetzt plötzlich geht es nach dem
wahlkampf also es geht viel mehr als man
immer glaubt also ich bin wäre jetzt
nicht stolz drauf wenn shutter und
maßnahmen gehen oder nicht gehen also
das ziel von politik muss immer sein den
größtmöglichen freiheits spielraum zu
ermöglichen und nicht so hart wie
möglich mit den eigenen leuten um zu
springen die liste der linien länder die
lockern ist auch viel länger ganz
skandinavien bis finnland aber auch die
schweiz österreich hat zwar die
unterricht eingeführt lockert aber auch
spanien lockert es gibt eine ganze reihe
von maßnahmen bei uns die auch nicht
plausibel sind also ein ausgehverbot für
ungeimpfte nach 22 uhr wenn dort von den
15 leuten auf der straße sind einer
ungeimpft ist dann schadet das niemanden
und das ist einfach vielfach unsinn also
mit einer normalen maske im einzelhandel
mit mit großen flächen da kommt man
prima durch und man muss dann nicht
ewige kontrollmechanismen richten das
funktioniert schon alles dafür dass man
diese zweig regel einzelhandel die wird
jetzt teilweise auch gewöhnt manchmal
schon aufgehoben und halte ich völlig
fertig wird für zu recht also bei
basiert dann ihr wissen ich brauche mehr
weiß man wie sich wer wo an steckt ja
das ist wieder da reden da sprechen es
allerdings ein großes problem an
deutschland weiß eigentlich so gut wie
nichts wir wissen nicht mal die genaue
zahl der impfungen weil wir die aus den
dosen hochrechnen wir nehmen eine
ampulle und rechnet hoch dass er 67
dosen rausgekommen sind wir haben
eigentlich statistisch so gut wie nichts
gelernt wir haben nicht erfasst wo die
leute sich angesteckt haben viele wissen
es nicht aber da wo man es weiß kann man
bei mehreren millionen geimpften oder
erkrankten hätte man es erfassen können
wir haben es nicht erfasst der
datenschutz verhindert bei uns
eigentlich alle kenntnis über das virus
und wenn sie nachfragen wie die
bettenbelegung in den krankenhäusern ist
dann stellen sie fest dass auch zum teil
leute mit unklarem erkrankungsbild als
omikron eingestuft worden sind in
sachsen anhalt wie vision die zahlen bis
zu 29 prozent ab die alle unter corona
subsumiert worden sind das kann man
alles in die tonne treten das
funktioniert alles so nicht da haben wir
ein riesenproblem da können wir weiter
sein wenn wir belastbare statistiken
hätten müssten wir mehr das ist das ist
zweifellos richtig hautkontakt kann der
sind sie für lockerung sagen sie
dadurch dass omikron milden verlauf oft
hat die leute inzwischen auch gelernt
haben mit dem virus umzugehen halt eben
viele halten die meisten halten sicher
daran maske testen all dass man sagen
kann man muss die bürger eigentlich eben
man muss ihnen mehr eigenverantwortung
geben im umgang mit dem virus
nein das ist jetzt noch zu früh weil der
peak ja noch vor uns liegt wir wissen
nicht ganz genau wann wir ihn erreichen
werden wahrscheinlich in zwei bis drei
wochen und wenn wir das dann überwunden
haben werden diesen weg der mikrowelle
dann ist der zeitpunkt gekommen wo man
natürlich auch einschränkungen langsam
zurücknehmen kann das ziel muss ja sein
dass wir einen in de mission in dem
ische situation bekommen ja dass wir mit
einem virus so umgehen können und leben
können dass er eben nicht das
gesundheitssystem überlastet dass er
nicht die kritische infrastruktur
überlastet und dass er nicht zu so
vielen todesfällen führt wie wir sie
jetzt im moment haben und darf aber im
moment in unserem labor laden eine hohe
aber im moment ist das system nicht da
gehe ich sofort drauf aber ganz kurz den
gedanken zu ende gebracht dafür ist die
grundlage eben eine hohe impfquoten und
die haben wir in deutschland jetzt noch
nicht und wird es ist noch überhaupt
nicht ausgemacht dass nicht das
gesundheitssystem da wo wir die
impfquote noch relativ gering haben wie
beispielsweise auch in bayern leider die
ja im moment die höchsten instanzen
haben und eine impfquote unter dem
bundesdurchschnitt oder auch in den
östlichen ländern dass das
gesundheitssystem wenn wir den peak
jetzt erreichen werden nicht doch noch
mal sehr stark unter druck kommt und
auch der expertenrat
die bundesregierung berät hat ja gesagt
gerade auch die belastung der kritischen
infrastruktur steht uns wahrscheinlich
noch bevor und was war konnte man gesagt
hat dass dieses omikron virus eben in
der regel so harmlos verlaufen würde das
ist ja nur partiell richtig es verläuft
bei denen in der regel harmlos die
geimpft sind und auch noch gemeistert
sind aber wir haben schwere verläufe in
allen altersgruppen und wir haben
offensichtlich auch eine relativ hohes
risiko für lancôme witt verläufe und
auch das darf man nicht auf die leichte
schulter nehmen das heißt wenn wir über
zuversicht sprechen und dafür bin ich
sehr viel zuversicht dann heißt das wir
können dann anfangen zu lockern wenn
unsere importe deutlich
über dem liegt was wir jetzt haben und
den peak der mikrowelle uk
position ist klar frau kornemann sagen
sie es ist zeit für lockerungen jetzt
ja denn
wir reden in diesem rahmen sehr viel
über wissenschaft und zur wissenschaft
gehört dass die politik wir gemeinsam
gesagt haben wir stellen oft bestimmte
dinge ab also zuerst war es die neue
infekt sich bei uns in gent später was
die hospitalisierung since events und
wenn diese zurückgehen dann müssen die
konsequenzen folgen und gelockert werden
und dass ich sehr irritierend finde ist
die tatsache dass jetzt neben diesen ins
identisch zu denen wir uns bekennen
ständig neue kriterien geschaffen werden
also herr lauterbach spricht jetzt von
den kriterium der toten herr kretschmann
spricht davor davon dass vor ostern
sowieso nichts möglich sein kann da es
stellt sich für mich schon die frage
geht es dann noch um corona oder geht es
um kontrolle und wenn wir den cup das
vertrauen der bevölkerung nicht
vollständig einbüßen wollen dann müssen
wir auch wort halten das heißt nur der
wahnsinn da machen die schotten machen
diesmal kommt der infracor werden was
was sollte jetzt aufgehoben werden
sollte die masken pflicht fallen sollten
sollten über als vage regeln fallen was
würden so sollte es eine art frieden
geben wo man sagt ab jetzt ist alles
offen was würden sie jetzt machen
es sollte zum beispiel wie zwei giebel
und fallen denn wir haben weder für die
eine noch für das andere die belege dass
mit 3g oder mit zwei gehen die zahlen
höher oder niedriger sind im gegenteil
entscheidend ist dass abstand gewahrt
wird dass ich ein stückchen immer
abhängig von fläche und von diesem
hintergrund tun wir gut daran uns auch
in den anderen ländern um zu sehen aber
beispielsweise auch in ländern wie
nordrhein westfalen in denen es auch
fällt oder versuche gegeben haben wie
zum beispiel eine große kirmes in soest
zu keinem weiteren infektionsgeschehen
geführt hat das heißt zweig sollte in
jedem fall fallen was zu vertrauen auch
dazu gehört wäre die wieder anerkennung
des gewesenen status denn es ist ja
schon ein unding dass binnen einer nacht
und nebelaktion der genesenen status von
sechs auf drei monate verkürzt worden
wobei wie auch die deutsche gesellschaft
für urologie sehr deutlich sagt wir
dürfen von einem mindestmaß von sechs
monaten ausgehen in resteuropa sechs
monate gelten nur in deutschland gibt es
einen alleingang ohne wissenschaftliche
begründung und belegt und das kostet
vertrauen okay wenn wir gibt also
sondern bestehen wollen dann müssen wir
am ende die bevölkerung mitnehmen und
das gilt eben nur an dann auch mit einer
wissenschaftlichkeit und am ende auch
einer belastbarkeit der
maßgeblich muskelspielen blick auf so
als wäre sie sagen lockern und frau
satori ganz genesen status weil das
immer unter untergeht das bezieht sich
diese verkürzung des genesenen status
bezieht sich nur auf ungeimpfte dasteht
zwei mal dick auf der seite von robert
koch-institut fettgedruckt von anfang an
das geht in der diskussion leider unter
wer geimpft ist zwei mal und dann
genügen dann genesen das verkürzt sich
nicht der hat weiterhin gleich erlangen
so den status geben ja aber da ist ja
immer diese stadt aber nicht verlängert
jetzt genau aber es verlängert sich ja
dadurch seine gültigkeit also es beginnt
nur für ungeimpfte menschen und es ist
sehr wohl wissenschaftlich begründet
wenn sie sich die seite vom lka morgen
der steuer mehrere stunden hier und es
ist sehr wohl wissenschaftlich begründet
weil man weiß dass eine einmalige
infektion mit micr on ein ganz ganz
schwachen schutz nur bildet wird kein
der übrigens nicht reichen wird um mehr
über den herbst zu kommen auf den ärger
auf der rk ii seite ist eine ganz
wichtige studie vom von der stiko drauf
die empfehlen frühestens nach drei
monaten zu impfen nachdem nachdem
genesen nachdem genesen daraus zieht das
rk ii den schluss der genesenen status
wird auf drei monate verkürzt das ist
irgendwie selber macht ja keine impfung
die stiko sauber beruf gibt es um die
studios und das ist auch nicht windig
die gucken sich an welche studien gibt
es zu diesem thema welche sind gut
gemacht und die langsam das ist sehr
anerkanntes instrument in der
wissenschaft dass man guckt dass man
nicht nur auf eine studie gibt sondern
auf mehrere die werte ich aus um dann zu
gucken was sagt die studienlage
insgesamt von internationalen studien
auch die stiko selber macht
die sechs monate sind sehr gut begründet
es gibt noch kein grund das mal
abgesehen davon dass ja lauter
nachweislich gelogen hat weil er schon
vorher wusste das ist verkürzt wird ich
würde gerne in die letzte minute einfach
mal zu gucken wir haben ja wir haben ja
gelernt das ist ein ziemliches
ziemlicher zick zack kurs ist mit corona
und viele leute auch wirklich irritiert
sind nicht mehr wissen was jetzt wie
gilt wie kriegen kriegt man vertrauen
zurück und kriegt man das vertrauen so
zurück dass das die bürger weiter auch
bürgerinnen und bürger auch weiter
mitmachen frau capa gold was ist da
jetzt was wäre jetzt die richtige
maßnahme dass die bürger eben nicht alle
sagen ich verstehe es nicht mehr ich
will es nicht mehr und dann sozusagen
eben nicht mehr teilhaben in der
bekämpfung
sie ich bin sehr dafür zu sagen was der
fall ist und nicht dinge zu versprechen
die nachher nach hinten losgehen und
wenn es jetzt dieses narrativ geht es
kann jetzt
gelockert werden obwohl wir den peak
noch nicht erreicht haben von omikron
und omikron eben alles andere als
harmlos ist dann geben wir ein
versprechen und
unterstellen dass wir da etwas erreichen
können was nicht der fall sein wird
sondern wir werden wenn wir jetzt zu
früh lockern ebenso was wieso ein
backlash kriegen und dann gehen die
instanzen wieder nach oben die
todesfälle nach oben die
hospitalisierung rate nach oben und da
muss man wieder eine eine bremsung
machen und das halte ich für völlig
falsch ich würde jetzt kurs halten und
das eben gut begründen es lässt sich
wissenschaftlich sehr sehr gut begründen
und gleichzeitig die allgemeine
impfpflicht für über 18-jährige
einführen um dann eben wirklich eine
zuversichtliche haltung einnehmen zu
können die sagt dann können wir diese
pandemie endlich gemeinsam überwinden
frau connemann behält man kurs auch
gemeinsam kurs und so dass die
bürgerinnen und bürger ist auch
verstehen mit der bitte um eine etwas
kürzere hand mit blick auf die zeit mit
transparenz mit offenheit und am ende
auch mit belastbarkeit und dazu gehören
eben dinge wie verkürzung genesenen
status nicht denn die menschen im land
sind nicht dumm die gucken sich
umschauen auch über die grenzen des
landes nach europa und wenn in ganz
europa wir genießen den status das heißt
die antikörper sechs monate und länger
wirken sollen und nur in deutschland
gesagt wird hier geht ein sonderweg wenn
ich das nicht überzeugend insbesondere
wenn wissenschaftliche quellen muss da
sind das heißt lasst uns auf die
wissenschaft hören aber dann wieder auch
reagieren sonst entsteht die gefahr dass
ich nicht mal um corona geht sondern um
kontrolle das wäre nicht gut der schule
was würden sie sagen erstens mal nicht
ständig mit den begründungen hin und her
hüpfen jetzt viel gerade das stichwort
longo wird als begründung warum genau da
beim diese ganze haltung das volk der
böse lümmel hat einmal gesagt die müssen
wir davor bewahren über die stränge zu
schlagen dass das kann ich einfach nicht
mehr hören das andere ist einfach mal
eine ganz nüchterne sichtung all der
maßnahmen die inzwischen aufgelaufen
sind auf ihre sinnhaftigkeit im stadion
was 60.000 leute fasst sitzen 3000 auf
einer seite zusammen das ist doch unsinn
das ist freiluft die kann man verteilen
da haben sie abstand und wir haben immer
noch links in einem hotel sich
entgegenzukommen mit maske dreifach
geimpft und dann sichteten die
plexiglasscheibe gegenüber zu stehen ist
einfach irre story
ich glaube nur allgemeine impfpflicht
die mehrheit dieser menschen hat sich
impfen lassen einmal zweimal dreimal die
wäre auch bereit sich noch mal impfen zu
lassen weil sie sich davor schützt weil
die leute zum großen teil angst vor
diesen virus haben und zwar zu recht und
sie sehen es nicht mehr ein warum eine
kleine minderheit von menschen sagt ich
lasse mich nicht impfen und wir deswegen
all diese maßnahmen vor allem machen
müssen das ist das ja hauptsächlich und
wenn wir diese im flug nicht schließen
dann haben wir ein mögliches problem im
nächsten herbst das es übrigens
wissenschaftlich belegt weil man weiß
dass dreimal sehr gut schützt egal was
da kommt das verbessert insgesamt sind
im status und ich glaube die leute
wundern sich dass die politik der
sozialist und sagen hey wir haben
geliefert warum liefert ihr jetzt nicht
damit endlich auch hier da gibt es
glaube ich hier auch eine einigkeit dass
alle sagen mehr impfen das ist das was
hilft also vielen dank für diese
diskussion vielen dank ihnen fürs
zuschauen morgen sind wir wieder für sie
da und fragen einkaufen heizen tanken
wer kann sich das noch leisten und jetzt
gibt's wenig der tag mit meiner kollegin
konstanzer après ski bis dann
[Musik]